"All these people working together
to help me, Mr. serial killer
Make that Mr. serial killer and son."
Hey guys, Pete here. Today i'm talking about the
ending of Dexter New Blood. Episode 10 brought
the limited series to a conclusion and provided
an unambiguous ending for the character Dexter
Morgan. I'll be recapping the main points of what
happened in the finale which was titled "Sins of
the Father" and then talk about what the ending
was trying to convey. we'll be getting into all of
that right after a quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 10 of Dexter new blood
then this video won't be for you and with that
out of the way let's get into it. Dexter Morgan is
dead. there's not even really any wiggle room
there they, decided to kill him off and it's done.
in order to understand how we got there we do
have to look back at the original series finale
the 12th and final episode of its eighth season
at the end of that Dexter had abandoned his
son Harrison thinking he was better off with
his girlfriend Hannah who was also a killer.
they traveled to Argentina to start a new
life knowing that she would never recover
he unplugged his sister Deb's life support after
she slipped into a coma he dropped her body into
the ocean and then drove his boat into hurricane
Laura and New Blood clarified that he was trying
to end his life here. laura is a reference to his
biological mother's name and of course witnessing
her death as a child was the foundational
event that defined most of Dexter's life
after he survived the hurricane he explained in a
letter that he sent to hannah that the experience
showed him that he had to bear the burden of his
urges alone in his mind he would leave everyone
behind live in a self-imposed exile where he
wouldn't be in a position to endanger anyone
but himself after the loss of Deb he realized that
everyone he cares about that stays close to him
suffers because of what he does they all
eventually die and we will come back around
to this letter at the end and discuss how it
informs his decisions at the very end of his life
the season 8 finale ended with Dexter alone
working as a lumberjack somewhere in Oregon
at the beginning of new blood we learned that
his self-imposed exile included remaining
abstinent from indulging his dark passenger he
gone almost 10 years without killing anyone and
managed to put together about as normal of a life
as he could hope for living under the assumed name
Jim Lindsay and working at the local fish and game
store while he still goes to great lengths to try
to look normal and blend in he did decide to enter
into a relationship with the local chief of police
the implication is that he wanted to stay close
to the action more than he wanted to completely
limit the chances that his real identity might
be exposed it's a classic situation where dexter
wants to control everything around him and this
time it does come back to bite him in the end
things start to get disrupted in this newfound
normal life he's built on routine when two sons
arrive in Iron Lake Matt Caldwell the son of a
successful local businessman he'll become dexter's
first kill in a long time in a situation where
he bends the code almost to absurdity because
this guy really rubs him the wrong way and his
son Harrison also arrives who is fresh off of
an awful experience with the foster care system
after losing his adoptive mom hannah who dexter
left him with to cancer initially Dexter tries to
turn Harrison away telling him he's made a mistake
that he's jim lindsay and he's not his father
but after he kills Matt he decides to tell him
the truth he welcomes his son into his life and
they struggle to connect until he realizes that
Harrison struggles with violent urges related to
his past he focuses in on the fact that they both
witness their mothers being murdered and decides
that he'll come clean and tell him everything
he tells him that he has similar urges and that
his adoptive father harry taught him a way to
control them by using a code to kill people
who the justice system has failed to catch
being a vigilante sounds good to harrison at
first and they do kill Kurt Caldwell together
in the penultimate episode and in the lead-up to
the finale dexter thinks he's finally found what
he always wanted someone who knows what he is
and what he does and can accept him at the same
time his girlfriend Angela who'd grown suspicious
after learning about him faking his death started
to put together the pieces to connect him to the
Bay Harbor Butcher killings from his past this
was helped along by kurt sending her surgical
screws as evidence that he killed his son matt
and in the beginning of the final episode she
discovers another one of the set in the ruins
of dexter's burnt down cabin that will lead to his
arrest but before she's able to do that we get our
first glimpse of how the curt kill has changed
dexter's mindset he's looking around and notices
how many nice and helpful people live in iron
lake and realizes that they'll have to leave in
order to have more victims harrison is reluctant
because he finally feels like he fits in somewhere
but dex explains they'll need to satisfy their
urges to keep the dark passengers at bay it's in
this moment that you realize that this is more
about his desires than what's best for his son
angela takes him into custody and you see the
moment when she loses any doubt she might be wrong
as he hears the charges dexter says matt's dead
and the effortlessness of the lie seems to confirm
her suspicions he's booked as dexter morgan
not jim lindsey and when they sit down for the
interview she says hello dexter morgan which is a
nice call back to the trinity killer she presents
him with the evidence she has which to his credit
isn't very strong and he does his normal routine
of doing a pretty good job of talking his way out
of it he makes a fairly compelling case sinking
on his feet after hearing her working theory and
using the fact that kurt had a grudge against her
for his arrest it all ties into him burning down
the cabin so the screw would be found and when he
pivots to try to start talking about the problems
she's having related to learning about iris he
really pushes a button which prompts logan to come
in and break things up when logan and angela talk
he points out that dexter's story is plausible
enough to sway a jury and therefore a da will
be hesitant to file charges of course she has a
lot more on her mind because of her investigation
into his connection to the bay harbor butcher but
she still isn't ready to mention those suspicions
and holds back on this initially because she
feels like she needs to be sure this time
dexter is allowed to meet with harrison for five
minutes and he explains that he has nothing to
worry about because it's not related to kurt
and assures them that he's been in tougher spots
before and that they'll get out of it they hug and
he tells him that the world needs us implying that
the world needs this kind of vigilante justice
that only they can deliver and you can see that
this doesn't have the intended effect on harrison
he looks conflicted about it logan and harrison
have a moment in his room at the tavern and
basically he realizes what a good guy he is
angela decides to call batista and
ask about the bay harbor butcher case
she asked him if he believed that dokes really
did it which he did at the time but he also
brings up that his ex-wife maria laguerta thought
that it was dexter morgan only he died years ago
she sends him a picture of them together to
show that he's still alive and he immediately
says that he'll be there first thing tomorrow
morning and he'll be bringing everything he has
with this new information angela returns to
interview dexter again she brings up the ketamine
and then shows him everything she's got that
makes her believe that he's the bay harbor butcher
there's a point where i think she lets her
emotions get the best of her telling him
that batista was coming there the next morning
it's here where you see him change his strategy
instead of riding it out and hoping that her weak
evidence won't hold he decides to try to get her
out of the station so he can try to find a way
to escape he tells her to turn off the camera and
when she eventually does he tells her about kurt's
underground bunker this really serves no purpose
for him except buying a little time and in that
that makes her only appearance before the very end
over the course of the season we had been seeing
less and less of deb in each episode as dexter
started to embrace his old self and decided
to expose everything to harrison he stopped
allowing that voice of doubt that comes through
deb to influence his decisions he or she reminds
him about how earlier in the season he started
thinking that not killing might be the problem
and when she doubts his ability to get around
angela he gets angry and then calls for logan to
bring him some water he uses this as a chance to
try to force him to let him go he smashes his face
against the bars and then he gets him in a choke
hold he gives him the opportunity to unlock the
cell and just let him go so he can go see harrison
but logan makes the decision to go for his gun and
tries to shoot dexter who then snaps his neck
killing him this is a point of no return there
isn't much he can do besides take his keys and try
to leave and he calls harrison with logan's phone
and tells him to get his truck and meet him where
they found the white deer at the same time angela
arrives at kurt's cabin and finds the bunker she
goes inside and discovers all the bodies in the
trophy cases and after putting everything together
and seeing molly park's body there she comes up to
call for backup she obviously can't reach logan
so she calls teddy and finds out that he hasn't
talked to him in the last hour she rushes back
to the station to find his body and learns that
dexter escaped when he meets up with harrison
covered with blood in the woods his son wants to
know where it came from he realizes that it came
from logan because he called him from his phone
and dexter tries to tell him there was no other
way he goes further to try to make it about him
saying it was the only way i could get back to you
and goes as far as saying that i need to be with
you none of this is really landing because of what
happened to get them to that point harrison really
begins to question if they're the same after
all he was on board because he thought about
it as saving innocent lives but here he sees the
failings and how innocent people can get swept up
in it too he decides that he doesn't want to leave
town together he wants it to end and he thinks
that his father needs to turn himself in dexter
explains that he would get the death penalty
which means he won't do that and his son says
maybe that's what you deserve realizing that he's
running out of time dexter tells harrison that he
doesn't have to come along but that he can't stay
there anymore as he's walking away harrison pulls
out his rifle and demands to know if his mother
and his aunt deb would still be alive if it wasn't
for dexter and when he says open your eyes and
look at what you've done saying the same words
that dexter said in the very first kill that we
saw in the first season it finally hits dexter and
he thinks of some of the innocent people that died
as a direct result of his inability to stop
killing in that moment he decides to make
the ultimate sacrifice for his son he tells
him that he's sorry for everything he's done
that he deserved better a better life a better
father and realizing that he was about to walk
away from the son that had waited to be together
for so long and had felt abandoned for all these
years he breaks down and he tells him that he has
to take the safety off just like i showed you and
assures him that this is the only way out and they
both understand this they understand that they're
trapped in this cycle and this is the only way
it can come to an end he guides him to shoot him
in the heart and just before that happens we hear
in voiceover i've never felt real love until now
meaning this one selfless choice made for his son
felt right and you hear him say you did good as he
expires with his sister deb holding his hand as he
goes angela shows up and tells harrison to get out
of there she gives him some cash tells him to take
the truck gives him directions and tells him never
to come back she cleans off his prints and calls
it in to take responsibility for it herself we
see that he has kurt's cash and when he's getting
ready to leave the scene he sees the letter that
dexter sent to hannah this reminds the viewers
that he had already come to this conclusion before
harrison re-entered his life as we hear him read
it in voiceover we understand that he went against
his own plan and welcomed harrison back into his
life because he couldn't bear to send him away in
that moment he hoped that he could make it work in
spite of the fact that he was already picking up
on his old behaviors when the prospect came up to
be himself and bring harrison along for the ride
he jumped at it and in the end he was ready to
abandon him again if he wasn't willing to accept
character and the letter reinforces that he always
knew that harrison would be better off without him
he did what he thought he had to do to give him a
chance and he accepted that it was his sacrifice
to make it's not the kind of end that will
satisfy everyone who wanted the story to continue
but it's the one that they set up and delivered
let me die so my son can live he went out on his
own terms and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you think about it in the
comments it's certainly divisive i knew a lot of
people were going to be disappointed and not like
the finale if he died based on the feedback to my
last couple of videos where i said that i thought
that was the most likely outcome and it wasn't a
perfect season or finale it had its issues i think
that's pretty standard for dexter and i think
everyone has their own limits on what they're
willing to overlook and if they would have got the
ending they wanted they would have been happy to
overlook those things i think they rejuvenated
the character they brought back the excitement
and the tension from the early seasons and i think
we saw some of michael c hall's best acting from
the entire series so i'm not mad i decided to
watch it dexter dying was inevitable and it looks
like clyde was right it did break the internet
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon